let's talk to people in the audience
people in the audience uh we do this via
discord davidpakman.com
discord
um and uh let's see who's uh who who
wants to chat today let's start today
with aaron from los angeles california
aaron you were on the air
david uh i just wanted to ask you uh
real quick because i know that you've
spoken this on this a bit but um what's
your opinion on let's say a revolving
door or like an open door uh
border policy because uh um i've been
reading a lot and i've like actually
although
i'm not a really big fan of reagan one
of the few things i did enjoy i did like
about his
um about his policies were his
immigration policies such as like the
broadcerdo program
and different programs such as like
granting amnesty to the undocumented
immigrants i was just wondering what's
your take on uh immigration well when
you say revolving door or open door
would you you mean just anybody can come
in and out work
no screening whatsoever what what do you
mean specifically yeah um well like or
you know at least alleviating it for
seasonal workers to be able to come in
during the um
um
agricultural seasons when it's busy and
then allowing them to return at any time
usually during the off season to go back
home yeah i i a lot of those things i'm
very much in favor of i do think there
need to be some immigration controls i
am not for an open border i am i am not
for
uh this sort of fully libertarian
libertarian idea of
total free movement of labor and people
i i just practically speaking i don't
think that that would work but we've got
to give permanent status to daca
recipients number one guest worker
program absolutely
people often when they say shut this
down shut that down they don't
understand not only the degree to which
industries are dependent on
workers from other countries sometimes
undocumented but also
why some of the things that they have
are far cheaper as a result of that
labor and it's very hypocritical when
you hear people who want the cheap stuff
if stuff gets more expensive they would
attack whoever the president is but they
also want that very same president to
quote keep people out incoherent doesn't
make sense and i'm for a whole bunch of
the things you're proposing not open
borders but for a lot of the things
you're talking about yes
okay uh in terms of border security
though how would that work because from
my understanding our current state of
border security is not only notoriously
corrupt but it's also just like not
working i mean uh people are still able
to like
it's mostly there to be able to prevent
um i guess like drug traffickers from
coming in but they're still managing to
like come in at a rate that benefits
their type of business and industry so i
was just wondering like in terms of
border security how should we reframe
that so it's not just like a black hole
that we're just spending a lot of the
taxpayer money on well two things we are
disproportionately focused on people
just physically crossing the border
rather than people flying in and just
staying here or coming in with a visa
and staying so one of the first things
you have to think about is
you can
disincentivize people from doing the
illegal crossings by making it less
necessary to do that and so a lot of the
programs you're talking about guest
worker programs etc
they they remove a lot of the need to
come in the way that you're talking
about so we just need to be thinking
about it you're completely right that if
you just change one thing it doesn't
change the entire dynamic we need to be
thinking much bigger
thank you david appreciate the call
thank you so much there's aaron from los
angeles
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers ingredients and recipes
for artisan cocktails right to you i've
been having fun using shaker and spoon
to make cocktails at home one of my
favorite is citrus paradisi great blend
of vodka tonic lime green tea and rose
rose
you open up the box the whole
presentation is awesome they've got all
the ingredients except the alcohol and
really easy instructions even if you
know nothing about mixing drinks like me
you're still going to have fun and
create drinks that turn out really well
i've been impressed with the results
i've gotten with the shaker and spoon
recipes you learn a lot about mixing
drinks it's fun to do on a date night
it's a great time and it makes a perfect
gift because you're giving someone a
really cool experience shaker and spoon
is giving you 20 off when you use promo
code pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com pacman and the link
is down below